[Music]
good morning John it's Friday August
31st I don't know if you hear that
buzzing noise in the background but
that's you mowing the lawn I remember in
high school you thought you had a really
great idea and the really great idea was
to have a band and call it mow and the
lawns I'm guessing you don't think
that's a really great idea anymore
know what I think about that though I
guess you know remember that you
actually wrote songs for mowing the
lawns did you actually write songs Ramon
the lawns and if so uh can I see them if
you're holding out on me big brother I'm
not going to forgive you any John Green
original music is definitely part of
this project and I want to see it
Katherine and I are about to go back to
Montana and while that's sad it's also
very happy I miss home and I miss my cat
and my friends and um regularity my
barber and grocery store honey bunches
of oats $0.50 corn dogs our garden uh
sanity don't get me wrong it's been
wonderful but there's something to be
said for home and I'm looking forward to
being home even though I'm not going to
be there until like 1 o'clock tomorrow
morning labor pains don't I had the
phone call with the YouTube partnership
people yesterday and if you're wondering
about the contents of that strictly
confidential phone call I will tell you
it was a fascinating 45 minute lecture
on copyright laws uh and that's pretty
much all I did learn one thing though
and that's that a dance can be
copyrighted if a dance is choreographed
then that dance is copyrighted which is
very sad because it means that I can no
longer do the Macarena on my YouTube
videos also since John and i's happy
dances are choreographed dances i will
sue your ass if I see you doing my happy
dance
oh brother Hadoop oh no happiness is
actually a license of the Creative
Commons license for distribution and
modification as you wish
however every person really kind of
should have their own happy dance
speaking of evidences you should know
that we will not be able to use any
sound that happens during your happy
dance because we will likely be playing
music over the whole project hopefully
some kind of music that isn't violating
copyright innominate Pittsburgh there
once was a farm that became an airport
that created a community connected to
the world here in Pittsburgh they're
really excited about the fact that they
have yesterday's airport of tomorrow
meaning today's airport the airport of
today again said about the tremendous
load of confidence for the airport that
I am currently in I'd rather be in like
you know today's airport of today I'd
rather not be yesterday's airport of
anything I miss you already John mostly
I miss the guest room in that big bed
that's in the guest bedroom anyway I
have to get on a plane so I'll see you
maybe on Monday maybe on Tuesday Monday
is Labor Day and that is an official
holiday however I don't feel like we
really qualify for Labor Day because
Brotherhood 2.0 doesn't really count as
labor you'd like a lift a tripod every
once in a while like the camera oh yeah
or the camera mmm
work that bicep so if you consider
brother fan 2.0 labor I guess you can
take Monday off and I'll see you on
Tuesday but otherwise I will see you on
Monday